hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason io
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
one of the virtues that aristotle
discusses along with its corresponding
vice is in both the nicomachean ethics
and also the
closely connected eudaimian ethics which
is
less often read but has some interesting
things to contribute
is what gets translated frequently as
liberality
the greek for that is which literally
means being a free person being the kind
acting like the
kind of person who understands their
their own freedom and what it means to
be a a free person but i think it's
better termed um in our contemporary
language generosity we we tend to
understand that a little bit better and
what is this concern with aristotle puts
his finger right on the
pulse of this
has to do with two different things that
are that are core relative to each other
giving or spending
and taking or getting and
of what time
energy no um
wealth
specifically money but also the things
that money can buy so could it include
time could it include
attention could it include things along
those lines yes it could include those
as well insofar as they are measurable
by money
but this has to do specifically with how
one uses their resources and how one
gets resources the in and out the ebb
and flow
and the directions that these things
take and the
habits remember virtues and vices are
habits the habits
the the
patterns
by which one one does these sorts of
things so it would also include the
models by which one one government
governs oneself
so let's start by thinking just in terms
really basic terms of the virtue being
the mean state between vices now
normally we say there is you know a
virtue and it's the mean it's the middle
state between an excess and a deficiency
on one side of the other but in this
case
the two vicious dispositions tend to
have vices that are connected with these
these two different correlatives so the
person who's on the vicious end of being
what we call stingy or
or a tight wad or there's a lot of
different names for that
is going to have a deficiency in giving
or spending
and they may also have an excess in
taking in the ways in which they take
and it won't just be a numerical excess
it will be excessive in other ways as
well that we'll talk about in a moment
on the other side
the person who is what we call a
prodigal which is not the best
translation
somebody who spends more than they ought
to they give more than they ought to
there's an excess there
oftentimes along with that there's a
deficiency in taking now as aristotle
notes this kind of person can actually
end up shifting over to this this side
in part because they spend everything
that they've got and now they have to
start you know getting away from the
deficiency and taking and start taking
from wherever they can get just so that
they can contin continue to give or just
to keep themselves afloat in fact the
greek word for what they were
translating as practicality
literally means something like being
without means assostos
the vice over here is just the opposite
as far as the greek goes
lyotheria analytheria meaning a lack of
electro theory a lack of liberality
a lack of generosity
so
what characterizes the generous person
is it just that they
are perfectly in the middle they don't
give too much sort of like goldilocks
not too much not too little
they don't take too much they don't take
too little
it's not that simple there's a number of
different characteristics that set apart
the liberal person from these these two
extreme vices one thing to keep in mind
as well and i'm going to try to close
with this too just to keep it
in everybody's memory
aristotle is very clear in talking about
this
in saying that not everybody
has this virtue or
one of these vices
some people don't fit any of them
that means that they're just sort of
perhaps you know going this way or going
this way but not already there
or they just don't have enough of a
subtle character one way or the other
the goal is to be virtuous not just to
not be vicious it's to be to be virtuous
so what is a generous person like in
aristotle's book or rather his books
there's a number of rights
virtue is always concerned with not just
the right amount which is going to be
very important for money
but also the right time the right
occasion for the right things
and to the right people
this is particularly important if we're
thinking about gifts if we're thinking
about charity if we're thinking about
you know reciprocity in in say buying
drinks or buying meals or things like
that
it's important that it be not just the
right amount but also with the right
persons and it will also have to do with
the person who is engaged in giving
if you have more then you can afford to
give more aristotle says that the
generous person does not give
so much that they can't they can't
possibly stay afloat themselves that
would actually be
over here that would be too much
too much for them
and what might be too much for me may
not be too much for somebody who's
earning twice the salary that i'm
earning or four times the salary they
probably ought to
give more they probably have greater uh
superfluities as he calls them now on
the other hand if somebody is earning
four times as much as i have but they've
got you know five kids to support maybe
they can't give as much maybe
they need to focus on what their what
their family requires maybe their their
generosity ought to be confined more
within those those bounds aristotle
doesn't discuss that that much in those
sections but that's that's a wrinkle
that you could introduce to it
in any case
the right amount is going to be
what is actually appropriate
so they're not going to be people who
throw their money around that's not real
generosity for aristotle that's
prodigality
they're going to do it at the right time
on the right occasions for the right
sorts of projects they're not just going
to you know throw money into just
anything
even if they have extra money laying
around they're going to actually pay
attention to what they're spending their
money on that's that's part of this the
person who's generous
is not somebody who doesn't value money
they are somebody who values money lower
than other certain things which we'll
get to in a moment but they do pay
attention to their money they pay
attention to their possessions they pay
attention to their resources because
those are things that you can actually
use
giving it to the right persons so for
example
um giving money to somebody who is
themselves
spendthrift prodigal is probably not a
good idea they're just going to waste it
you probably should do something like
put that money into a trust fund or
or dole it out you know a bit at a time
that would modify the amount right or
there could be some people who you just
shouldn't give any money to
there may be occasions on which you
should not give people money
so that's going to be important another
thing is they're motivated by doing
something that goes beyond the sphere of
just money
or even just financial security
aristotle thinks that financial security
is a good thing it's something that we
ought to value we do need in fact to
have certain means he would be perfectly
along
the the same lines are on the same page
as many of the money managers that are
out there who have you know radio shows
or books or things like that
in saying you need to pay attention to
your own resources you need to build
them up you need to restrict how much
you're spending on certain things and
who you're giving to
and you also need to think about you
know income streams and things like that
he would before that
but
here's the key question and and the
better money managers out there are very
attuned to this
what is what are you using the money for
what is the money intended to do
is it intended just to buy you a lot of
creature comforts
those are nice but that's not all that
life is about
is it just about feeling like a big shot
is it about dealing with the fears that
you might have from times when you
actually were destitute or strapped or
deep in debt and feeling like well i'm
not going to have that on my on my
back anymore it has to go beyond that
for aristotle in order to be this this
case this virtue of generosity
it has to be about doing what he calls
and the greeks have this category the
cologne
can be translated as beautiful can be
translated as honorable can be
translated as noble fine
you get the idea
something whose value
is recognizable
by
people who understand that sort of thing
so for example
do you spend the money
going around
doling it out to people who need some
sort of charitable
aid
or do you create something that would
say not only get them off the streets
but perhaps
seek to provide them jobs give them
training
that would be more in lines of what
aristotle is calling the
the generous
the
liberal person the the person who is
motivated by this does not reduce
everything down to the mere expedient or
the useful they recognize that there are
some things that are of higher value
friendship itself
cultivation of other people
helping them to steer themselves towards
virtue those would be things that would
fall under the cologne
promoting an artist who is actually
producing something that might be of
some social value or turn people's heads
towards other things that are cologne
rather than just
you know slapping paint around and
writing some political message or
something like that you know the things
that would be
the cologne
um you know
hiring an artist so that you look like a
big shot nah probably not so much though
the couple
there's one other thing that i really
want to focus on here and that is the
feelings of pleasure and pain
the person who has this virtue feels
pleasure in giving
they feel pleasure iris little says in
giving when it's the right time to give
if they're compelled to give more or to
the wrong things they will actually feel
a small amount of pain he says they'll
still do it
you know for example
bailing somebody out of jail is probably
a case where even if you are generous
you ought to feel like oh man
i really gotta spend my money on this
there's so many other better things i
could be spending it on but you know
this person needs my help they're
probably you know a friend or a family
member
or perhaps even a colleague
i'll do it for them but man that so you
would feel that sense of pain that's
very different than saying hey you know
what i think i could create a
scholarship for for this person or at
least contribute to it or you know even
think about micro lending right
micro lending could be a matter of the
the column and you should take pleasure
in in giving
you should also feel
some degree he says this in the
eudaimian ethics
some degree of pain when you're
dispensing your money or else you're
going to probably end up being
spendthrift because
you do want to be conscious of this
money managers are really smart with
this these days they say it's better to
do it with cash or a check because then
you actually see your money going out
rather than doing with credit cards
where it feels somewhat painless and can
get you deep in into debt and you might
say that credit cards are in fact
something that pushes people towards
this vice of prodigality in our own time
now let's look at these these vices so
let's start with practicality right
people who are prodigal
they give more than they ought to
to the wrong people on the wrong
occasions it could be that they do it
all the time or indiscriminately to
anybody who asks
they have a hard time saying no to
people a hard time saying no to things
they
may in fact be doing so because they
like the feeling that spending gives
them some people get addicted to
shopping and that would probably be a
form of prodigality aristotle would say
the shopping itself gives them a sort of
pleasure it makes them feel
like they say alive it gives them a
sense of of power
some people like spending money so that
they can have power over people uh so
that they can feel like they're
for once the big shot being attended to
being paid attention to that would uh
probably be prodigality as as well
rather than
the virtue of liberality
um
what else needs to be said they don't
they don't take rightly quite often
sometimes these are people who
want to give rather than take
and they don't pay attention to what
they're doing he talks about some people
who are prodigal don't like to keep
accounts they don't like to pay
attention to how much
is actually being spent or going out
uh in part i would i would guess he
doesn't completely you know spell this
out but in part because that detracts
from the pleasure of getting to spend
so now what's the problem with this well
there's really two problems two sets of
problems
one is if you do that sort of thing
pretty soon you can't be prodigal
forever right unless you have an
unlimited supply of wealth
um
in most cases you're going to burn
through your resources and then you're
not going to be able to give when you
ought to give
you won't be able to take care of even
your yourself or or your your family or
other you know obligations that you have
so that's one problem the other problem
is that this person has a screwed up
affective relationship with money or
wealth
they don't see what money really is for
it's not just for providing bare
necessities it's also not just
for spreading it everywhere and just
having a great time
it's for doing things that are
intrinsically
valuable worthwhile
elevated noble
this person may do some things they may
spend on some good things but they're
not doing that because they realize that
those are good things
they're how can you tell because they
don't they don't conserve their money
for those things they just you know
throw it everywhere and if some of it
happens to stick to the right things
then then they think great i'm i'm you
know a benefactor i'm a philanthropist
or something like that but they're not
really
they're just sort of
indiscriminately spending it
now aristotle actually thinks this kind
of person is
not as bad as this kind of person
that you can take people like that
and you can you know say sit them down
with the money manager and actually get
them to see oh man i shouldn't have all
these credit cards i actually
don't want to be in debt the rest of my
life you can actually get them to to
reason out what's good for them and to
shift over over this way so that's
that's good
some of the people on this end aristotle
actually considers incurable now you
know we could debate about that i'm just
telling you what he thinks
let's look at what the problems are with
this this other
extreme this other set of vices
there's a deficiency in giving
a reluctance to to spend money or
reluctance to you know let go of
possessions
um and there can also be an excess in
taking and these both stem
from
misvaluing misunderstanding the
relationship
between various kinds of goods they they
set money up or possessions up too high
and other things like say friendship
relationship self-respect
too low
and this can take a lot of different
forms aristotle says
some people are just stingy they don't
actually want what their neighbor has
they just want to hold on to what
they've got it could be because of fears
that they may end up in poverty
themselves or be be required to do
something that's the dishonorable to
make money so they just hold on to
everything and they say well i don't
give but i also don't take
and they feel themselves justified
because of that
that's not as bad as some of the other
manifestations over here but that's not
liberality and people like that
quite often look at people who are
liberal or generous and they say oh
those people just spend money like it's
going out of style
no they're spending the money on the
right things aristotle says that if you
actually are generous you focus more on
the giving and less on the taking
whereas these people focus on not giving
and i'm just keeping you know whatever
it is that they've got coming in
others take from the wrong sources
others go to access by by taking
in ways that they shouldn't from people
that they shouldn't more than they
should they might be greedy they might
be covetous they might look at their
neighbors stuff and say man i'd like to
have that
and aristotle talks is very interesting
here he talks about those who apply the
sordid traits
what does he mean there dishonorable
professions and he's not talking about
dishonorable professions like
sweeping floors or washing dishes or
things like that that he would probably
consider to be menial but still decent
work he's talking about pips
panderers he uses these terms
robbers
those who
get their friends involved in gambling
so that they can cheat their friends out
of money
these are the kind of people
that
they they do the wrong things to get
money they sell something else out they
don't realize that they're doing it in
part again because they they tend to be
focused more on what they're getting and
not what they're losing in the process
but aristotle says that that that sort
of thing is clearly on this side over
here it's an excess in in taking
core you know correlative to the
deficiency in giving
some people genuine genuinely are
greedy he talks about and those are the
people who are going to be very hard to
get out of this
notice that this can apply to a lot of
different situations it can have to do
with money itself
do you give gifts do you give charity
you know what do you spend your money on
it can
it can have to do with the relations
that we we have with people who we
purchase services from do we do so in a
generous way like a generous person
would do or in a stingy way or a greedy
way trying to squeeze everything we can
out of them
you know people who are involved in the
service industry they can tell when
you're doing that or do we just throw
money around and you know try to be good
time charlie to everybody
that's actually not a good thing
according to aristotle
you could think about other cases too
where where it's involved in the
reciprocity that takes place in
relationships and friendships
if somebody takes you out to dinner
the proper thing to do they have now
become a person that you ought in return
to give to
by taking them out to dinner now if
they're
rich and you're you know
struggling
and they take you out to a really nice
dinner at a fancy restaurant you may not
need to take them out to the same exact
thing that would probably be prodigality
you could take them out to a smaller
thing or take them out to coffee and say
yeah this is what i can't afford
but i did want to you know i did want to
give back to you through that
reciprocity the stingy person would say
well it's nice that you did that
see you later
or they never pick up the check or they
never get the round of drinks or you
know in the secret santa at christmas
time they never contribute you know
you've seen these types these are things
that we can easily identify i'm willing
to bet that in every one of your lives
you've seen some people who are prodigal
you've seen some people who are greedy
who are tight wads who do the wrong
things for money who are willing to sell
the wrong things out and you've seen
some people who actually are genuinely
generous or what aristotle would call
liberal minded
and these are the characteristics that
aristotle thinks that that they would
have
so
it's good to keep all of this stuff in
mind i think there there are a lot of
resources out there
that teach this sort of thing
productively
to people including a lot of the money
management
and even some self-help things
hopefully this has helped you to put
this in perspective so now you
understand aristotle's
views on this you can get past the
archaic
translated vocabulary that people are
using in aristotle style and see that
this is really
a set of concepts that apply to our
everyday life
you